as we mentioned next week's election
could be historic for women seeking
office in voters could send the first
female Muslims to Congress that includes
Michigan's Rashida to lead the Democrat
is running in Michigan's 13th district
House race Reena Ninan of our streaming
network that CBS n met with to lead to
discuss what this means for her and
Muslims Americans around the country
Reena good morning good morning to you
Gail well good morning as well
Rasheeda Talib is now facing a
last-minute write-in challenge from the
woman that she defeated in August but
the momentum is still with her campaign
she's an attorney a former state
legislator the oldest of 14 and also the
daughter of Palestinian immigrants and
she tells me she's looking to change
history at a time most people think it
just isn't possible the first thing I
think about when somebody says you're
gonna be the first Muslim as celebrate
this moment we changed the course of
history at a time
we thought it was impossible and that if
you just believe believe and the
possibility of someone like me this
isn't while many have focused on her
faith Rasheeda Talib says this moment is
so much more for it to happen at a
moment where we really have felt this
moment of Darkness at a moment where
Islamophobia is such a high rate like
you don't have to read the Koran to love
me love the actions love the things that
I do look at those and that will help
people get beyond whatever fear or
stereotypical thing that they might be
thinking about I will uplift you in so
many ways to leave wonder Democratic
primary in August and is running in
Michigan's 13th congressional district
if she wins next week she'll be one of
the first Muslim women in Congress what
was the moment where it hit you
I think it's hit me yet I think people
don't realize just how much of a roller
coaster it is and it's happy it's happy
chaos right now that's what I describe
it as do you believe that a Muslim wave
is coming to Congress I don't know I'm
all for not waves I'm all for owning the
ocean not Muslims but women
Talib joins the hundreds of women
running for office this year and like
many of these candidates she's also a
mom Talib was born in the mid 70s in
Detroit to Palestinian immigrant parents
her mom thought the mus as she always
believed her daughter would live the
American dream how does it feel to have
your daughter be the next woman does God
you know she thinks God I think I'm the
girl from southwest Detroit that didn't
speak English when I started school you
know I was my mother's translator and I
was probably 12 years old and I remember
how people looked at her I remember the
different things that were happening to
my family as as we were getting you know
situated and you know behind her first
home in southwest Detroit watching my
mother learned how to drive for the
first time all of those experiences come
with me and the cause closest to her
heart immigration reform your eyes well
up when you talk about immigration yes
why so I went to a predominately
african-american school I didn't even
understand like our immigration system I
knew my parents immigrated here I think
growing up in a community where your
neighbors are impacted directly it's
hard and talking about walls and
separation and detaining children I
think the immigration system we have
dehumanized it do you feel that the
Democratic Party is transforming into
something different I think everybody
transforms right organically I think it
is a new time it's a new era of the
civil rights movement it's time for a
change well to leave one Michigan's 13th
district primary it's roughly 60%
african-american she says it's all about
issues and she hopes to secure a $15
minimum wage plans to push for equal pay
and health care for all and of course
she's hoping to overturn the travel ban
which impacts several Muslim countries
you know regardless of who people end up
voting for it's so important to tell
these kind of stories because it's very
easy to vilify people right but when you
hear their backgrounds when you hear
their immigrant stories perspective yeah
yeah and you know she's part of a
working group of working-class Americans
who are coming into Congress and she
really believes that these are
shoes that haven't been tackled before
as aggressively and and it really
affects her and her 14 brothers it's a
big family day 1444 oldest of four teen
you said she likes happy chaos clearly
she does I don't hate that making her
where your family is your own voting
bloc Rena thank you